♪ ♪
>> Greg: YESTERDAY’S BRIEFING
WAS MORE LIKE A.
FIRST AFTER THE PRESS SPENT
WEEKS CONCOCTING A FANTASY RIFT
BETWEEN TRUMP AND FAUCI, THE
DOCTOR SHOWED UP TO AND THAT
DREAM.
SPEAK OF THE FIRST AND ONLY TIME
THAT DR. BIRX AND I FORMALLY
MADE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
PRESIDENT TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
"SHUTDOWN" IN THE SENSE OF NOT
REALLY SHUT DOWN, BUT TO REALLY
HAVE STRONG MITIGATION, WE
DISCUSSED IT.
OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD BE
CONCERNS BY SOME, AND IN FACT,
THAT MIGHT HAVE SOME NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
NONETHELESS, THE PRESIDENT
LISTENED TO THE RECOMMENDATION,
AND WENT TO THE MITIGATION.
>> Greg: SO TRUMP TOOK THE
EXPERTS ADVICE OF THE MOMENT IT
WAS OFFERED, AND HOW DID THE
MEDIA RESPOND?
DID THEY SAY, WE WERE WRONG TO
WASTE ALL AMERICA’S TIME WITH
CAFETERIA GOSSIP?
NO, THEY ACTED LIKE A BABY
LOSING THEIR FAVORITE TOY?
>> NO, EVERYTHING I DO IS
VOLUNTARILY.
PLEASE, DON’T EVEN IMPLY THAT.
>> Greg: IT HAS FINALLY
HAPPENED, EVEN THE CALMEST GUY
IN THE ROOM HEATS THE MEDIA IS
MUCH AS EVERYBODY ELSE DOES.
NOTE TO MEDIA, WHEN FAUCI THINKS
YOU SUCK, THAT IS A REAL
DIAGNOSIS.
TO TAKE TWO MONTHS OFF AND DON’T
CALL US IN THE MORNING.
AFTER WEEKS OF THE MEDIA
PRETENDING THEY WERE ON TOP OF
THE VIRUS WHILE CLAIMING TO BE
16 HAD BLOOD ON HIS HANDS, WHAT
DID HE DO?
WHAT ANY TV PRO WOULD DO,
DROPPING A MONTAGE TO SHOW HOW
WRONG THE MEDIA WAS.
>> HOW WORRIED SHOULD AMERICANS
BE ABOUT CORONAVIRUS?
>> IT IS HONEST, THEY HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIVE, LATE AT NIGHT, EARLY
IN THE MORNING, AND THEY HAVE
THUS FAR BEEN DOING EVERYTHING
THAT THEY CAN DO, AND I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU.
>> Greg: NOW THE MONTAGE WAS A
MEDIA TRICK THAT ONLY THE MEDIA
IS ALLOWED TO POOL, SO YOU KNOW
IT PISSED THEM OFF, HOW DARE HE
USE THEIR OWN WORDS AGAINST
THEM.
THAT IS PROPAGANDA.
THEIR INCONTINENCE AND OUTRAGE
SPILLED ONTO THEIR SCREENS.
CHECK OUT THE SWEATY CNN
HEADLINES, YOU CAN SEE THE STEAM
COMING OUT OF JEFF ZUCKER’S
EARS, AND WHY?
BECAUSE ONLY THE MEDIA HAS THE
POWER TO DESTROY YOUR
REPUTATION.
BUT DON’T YOU DARE TURN THE
TABLES ON THEM, WHICH TRUMP DID.
YESTERDAY HE ALSO MENTIONED THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXTRA
VENTILATORS, MAYBE SHOULD DROP
THEM OFF FOR TODAY’S BRIEFING.
BECAUSE MONTAGES ARE THE MEDIA’S
BREAD AND BUTTER, WE HAVE A
MONTAGE OF THE MEDIA RESPONDING
TO TRUMP’S MONTAGE.
MONTAGE VISA MONTAGE, LET’S
ROLL.
>> HE STARTED THE BRIEFING WITH
THAT PROPAGANDA VIDEO, WHICH IS
NOTHING SHORT OF DISGRACEFUL.
>> SOME KIND OF BACKWARD-LOOKING
EDITED VIDEO PROPAGANDA.
>> THAT WAS PROPAGANDA AIRED AT
TAXPAYER EXPENSE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM.
>> THIS IS A TEMPERAMENT ISSUE
WHERE HE IS CONSUMED WITH EGO
AND INSECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS COMBATIVE
AND ANGRY.
>> THAT IS THE BIGGEST MELTDOWN
I’VE EVER SEEN FROM A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IN MY
CAREER.
>> Greg: DANA, TO SEE PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA TALK ABOUT EGO
MAKES ME LAUGH HYSTERICALLY AT
THEM, DAVID GREGORY TALKING
ABOUT EGO AND ACTING AS THOUGH,
HOW DARE THEY USE THEIR OWN
WORDS?
THOSE WERE THEIR OWN WORDS, IT
IS NOT PROPAGANDA WHEN IT IS
THEIR OWN WORDS.
SORRY.
>> Dana: ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS TO DO WHEN I WAS A PRESS
SECRETARY WAS QUOTE SOMEBODY’S
WORDS BACK AT THEM.
SOMETIMES IT WAS THE MEDIA, BUT
OFTEN IT WAS WHATEVER THE
OPPOSITION WAS SAYING AT THE
TIME.
IT IS REALLY EFFECTIVE.
I DO LOVE IT THAT DR. FAUCI
FINALLY SAID ENOUGH.
HE HAS BEEN SO ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
SORTS OF MEDIA INCLUDING ALL OF
THE MAJOR NETWORKS.
BUT I THINK SOME OF HIS MOST
EFFECTIVE WORK HAS BEEN THAT HE
HAS SHOWN THAT HE IS ABLE TO DO
PART OF MY TAKE, HE IS
EVERYWHERE TO TRY TO SPREAD A
MESSAGE, BUT THE PROBLEM IS,
ONE, NEVER ANSWER A HYPOTHETICAL
HYPOTHETICAL, THAT IS P.R. 101.
NEVER ANSWER A HYPOTHETICAL,
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT THE DOCTORS
TO.
THEY ARE MEANT TO SHOW DIVISION.
AND THAT’S ONE OF THE REASONS
YOU NEVER ANSWER THEM, BECAUSE
THEY ARE NEVER A REAL ANSWER,
AND THEY WILL CHERRY PICK THINGS
TO TRY TO HURT YOU.
I’M GLAD DR. FAUCI PUSHED BACK
ON THAT.
AND WE ARE ALL BETTER OFF FOR
IT.
BECAUSE THE MORE THAT HE IS ABLE
AND WILLING TO GO OUT THERE AND
TALK TO ALL OF US, THE BETTER
OFF WE WILL ALL BE.
>> Greg: DANA, WHAT IF YOU
ENTERED A HYPOTHETICAL?
>> Dana: THAT IS A
HYPOTHETICAL, AND I WON’T ANSWER
IT.
YOU SEE HOW THAT IS DONE.
TRY AGAIN.
>> Greg: THAT’S WHY YOU ARE
THE PRESS SECRETARY AND I AM
JUST SOME SMOKE IN A SWEATER.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN, TAKE IT APART.
SAY HOW DISGUSTING AND
UNPROFESSIONAL IT WAS.
>> Juan: I’M GLAD YOU SAID IT.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT VIDEO, HE
DOES NOT JUST TAKE PEOPLE’S
WORDS, HE ACTUALLY OMITS WORDS
SO THAT THEY SAY THINGS THAT ARE
FAVORABLE TO HIM.
THAT’S WHY PEOPLE WOULD SAY THIS
IS A DISTORTION.
>> Jesse: HE LEARNED THAT FROM
CNN.
>> Juan: I DON’T CARE WHO HE
LEARNED IT FROM, HE IS THE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS OUR PRESIDENT, GREG.
HE HAS INFORMATION AT A TIME --
HE IS TOTALLY, THE WAY THAT HE
PUT FAUCI OUT THERE, LOOKED LIKE
HE WAS IN A HOSTAGE VIDEO.
>> Greg: OH, COME ON.
RIDICULOUS.
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY,
TODAY THE PRESIDENT, HANG ON,
GUYS.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT COMES OUT
WITH A TWEET IN WHICH HE IS
ATTACKING THE GOVERNOR?
HE IS LIKE THE CAPTAIN BLY ON
THE MUTINY ON THE BOUNTY?
SOMEONE HAS TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT THAT THE CAPTAIN BLY
IS A VILLAIN, THE CREW IS
ABUSED.
AND THAT’S WHY THEY REBEL
AGAINST HIM, AND YET THE
PRESIDENT SAYS, HE IS SEEING
MUTINY ON THE BOUNTY UNTIL THE
GOVERNORS THEY OWE THE CAPTAIN,
AND THE CAPTAIN HAS CONTROL.
IT’S LIKE AN ALTERNATE REALITY.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
HE SHOULD BE SAYING THAT HE IS
PROTECTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
NOT ABOUT TO ABUSE THEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE HAS BEEN
SAYING THAT.
>> Greg: SO JESSE, GIVE OUT --
WHILE HE IS RUNNING THE COUNTRY
AND DOING A GOOD JOB.
LET’S GET JESSE N.
>> Juan: GREG, CAN I MAKE ONE
QUICK POINT ON THAT?
>> >> Greg: ON HIGH POINTS.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS
THAT ARE UP IN ARMS SAYING HE
HAS TOTAL AUTHORITY.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE NEXT
BLOCK, JUAN.
ALL RIGHT, JESSE, THEN THE JUDGE
JUDGE.
>> Jesse: TAKE A LAP.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT
APPRECIATES THE COVERAGE OF THE
MEDIA AND TAKES BAD COVERAGE
VERY PERSONALLY AND HAS TAKEN IT
UPON HIMSELF TO POLICE THE
MEDIA.
AND THE MEDIA IS SQUEALING LIKE
A BUNCH OF STUFFED PIGS, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN POLICED
BEFORE.
REMEMBER, FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS IT WAS ONLY THE MEDIA
WHO HAD ACCESS TO RAW FOOTAGE
AND COULD EDIT TAPE AND
DISTRIBUTED.
NOW EVERY AMERICAN INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT HAS ACCESS TO THE SAME
FOOTAGE.
SO IT IS NOT PROPAGANDA WHEN YOU
SHOW THE MEDIA WHAT THEY SAID,
HE JUST HELD A MIRROR UP TO THE
MEDIA AND BASICALLY SAID, HOW
DARE YOU GET IT WRONG AND THEN
COME INTO A BRIEFING ROOM AND
WAG YOUR FINGER AT ME LIKE THAT.
AND THE POINT IS THIS, THERE IS
JUST A WRESTLING MATCH AT THIS
POINT BETWEEN TRUMP AND TO THE
PRESS OVER THE NARRATIVE.
AND THE NARRATIVE THEY WANT TO
SELL IS THAT TRUMP WAS LATE AND
WRONG.
AND TO THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING,
NO, I WASN’T.
PULLS OUT FAUCI.
AND SAYS EVERY SINGLE TIME I
MADE A SCIENTIFIC RECOMMENDATION
TO THE PRESIDENT, HE TOOK
IMMEDIATE ACTION.
THAT DESTROYS THE PRESS
NARRATIVE THAT SAYS THAT HE WAS
LATE AND WRONG AND ANYBODY THAT
EVER NOW FROM THIS DAY FORWARD
COMES UP ON THE SHOW, AND SAYS
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS LATE AND
WRONG, I AM PUSHING FAUCI IN
THEIR FACE AND I WILL DO IT WITH
PLEASURE.
>> Juan: YOU CAN PUSH FAUCI,
BUT NOT OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
WHAT, JUAN, LET ME TELL YOU
THIS, THERE IS NOTHING THAT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE TRUTH,
THE TRUTH IS THAT WHAT WAS PUT
UP BY THE PRESIDENT IS WHAT THEY
SAID.
PERIOD, AND OF THE STORY.
>> Juan: NOT TRUE.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY, LET ME
FINISH, JUAN.
THE REACTION OF FAUCI WHEN THEY
TRIED TO SAY, YOU ARE BEING
FORCED TO SAY THIS WAS SO
SHOCKING THAT EVERYONE LOOKED AT
AND SAID, THIS GUY IS SERIOUS,
HE IS NOT MAKING THIS STUFF UP.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN LIVING
FOR THREE YEARS WITH NETWORKS,
WAS CNN, MSNBC, WHO DO NOTHING
BUT CALL HIM NAMES 24/7.
HE HAS A RIGHT AT SOME POINT TO
DEFEND HIMSELF AND POINT TO THE
FACT THAT THERE PROPAGANDA IS A
LIE, AND THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT
IS WITH THEIR OWN WORDS.
PERIOD, AND OF THAT STORY.
>> Greg: HE BASICALLY HAS
SHATTERED THE MEDIA CEILING.
IT USED TO BE THAT THE MEDIA
COULD ONLY MANIPULATE THE
ENVIRONMENT.
HE IS SAYING, I WILL TAKE YOUR
WORDS INTO EXACTLY BACK TO YOU.
IT IS NEW GROUND.
YOU CAN ARGUE IT IS CHANGING